i'm not a dad i'm 48 my grandmother's 92
and she's like you'd be such a great dad
i'm like yeah you say that
and then you have the kid and then
you're like and then i know how much i
get mad at myself
and i'm like god i'm a terrible father
and i'm this and then i can't my
depression i can't sink any lower i
can't do it ernie i can't do that to
myself
i think don't you have to be mentally
prepared to have children well i think
you um
uh you know it's the only thing that i
ever wanted to do
i like you know people say well you want
to be an actor um but as a kid the only
thing i wanted you was to be a dad
because i didn't have a dad
i don't know which relationship you have
with your father but i didn't have a dad
uh i didn't know my mom so for me to get
the chance to be a dad was like
the ultimate most important thing ever
see that's right
i had to do it it's not that you're
better prepared but i will say
parenthood is not for everybody
and um and that's that's definite well
you know i look at that i look at your
story and i don't think a lot of people
know that but you know
you didn't know your father and your mom
passed away when you were just a couple
months old and i'm like
i had parents i was from a dysfunctional
family i mean we are dysfunctional i
mean if
the more you sit here with me you will
realize that ernie but how those
families are
i know everybody nobody gets a clear
break every family and one way or the
other
some more some go more than others i
will admit but
um yeah they're all dysfunctional but
but you said at a young age you were you
were like i want to be a dad was it
because you know he was like i didn't
have a dad
my mom i didn't know my mom i want to
have a family and create
this atmosphere that i didn't have as a
kid and this is what i want to create
some kind of like
something you didn't have is that it
yeah i think as a kid
and because you know i didn't nobody
knew who my father was
and so i would really young i would kind
of
latch on to men and kind of hang around
and hope they would kind of
you know like me and want to be my dad
and then they would always say get help
with me
and that was always so so i thought when
i grow up
i'm going to be a good dad and i'm going
to do all the things that nobody did
with me
and um and so yeah it was my way i
thought of
yeah doing and giving and being there
for somebody the way
nobody was ever there for me but i
realized later on
that your issues are your issues not
theirs
but still i will say being a parent was
the best thing ever happened to me i
think kids
will make you more than uh than what you
are you dig
so deep you know you go to places for
your kids that you wouldn't even
consider for yourself you know um
the things you can do that you kind of
go now i mean i can sleep
outside but my kid no i'm sorry but
you're
you're level-headed though like i i can
just tell by talking to you for like a
few minutes that
you know some of the roles you play are
not so level-headed
and then some of the rules you put so
it's all over i mean you're an actor
you're a great actor
so but then when you're a parent
how do you i mean you got to be the bad
cop sometimes you got to be the i mean
like my dad i'd rather him smack me in
the back than yell at me his voice was
so
powerful like don't ever let me tell you
that again
and i was like oh my god it was just
terrifying like did you have to hold
yourself back because
kids could piss you off and the worst
kids are kids that aren't yours
when you have kids over your house with
your friends kids
and they break you can't reprimand
the child you have to say uh
john uh could you talk to your child
that just broke my uh my uh
my star wars toy that i shouldn't have a
48 year old man